if you come back at a 10-year reunion
and say hey John everything I have look
at me now the guy's gonna laugh and be
like you did all of this to try and
prove me wrong man I feel sorry for you
when he said that when he actually
played out what my like Revenge fantasy
was in real life I realized it looks
stupid yeah the only thing that you can
do is win so big that all of them
constantly compare themselves to you and
then you'll forget they exist success is
the only Revenge it's not the best
revenge it's the only one there's no
other Revenge because everything else is
petty everything else does show that you
were thinking about these people all day
long which means they win by default